hi guys today I'm gonna be playing a
game that I am very excited for in his
friend Bo I played the demo a while back
it's a creepy point-and-click adventure
game and as most of you guys know I love
anything creepy so I have been looking
forward to this for a while I even wrote
an article on it and interviewed the
developers so you can check that out on
the link below but for now let's play
the game because this is what I have
been waiting for and totally a lot of
you guys as well because I know you
really enjoyed the demo let's do this it
feels like heaven I wonder if it's gonna
be the same as the demo I see my parents
it seems a little bit different I think
the music's different they look happy
they have a present for me I wonder you
already know who it is it's a cat so
sweet and pretty darkest deepest night
it's mr. midnight they've definitely
changed music I like it so happy my only
friend ah
we're having dinner and I see Aunt Grace
to you I really like her a lot
it's Friday my parents are going out
ask grayskin takes good care of me
we're having so much fun
keep mr. mee
it's Monday night I'm playing with mr.
midnight but something feels real bad oh
this is definitely creepier a strange
creature outside my window I don't like
it it scares me all this is so much
creepier I love it it's mom screaming I
want to know what's wrong a bright light
shines from my parents room I already
know what happens I go closer and closer
mom dad please don't oh no mommy daddy
oh gosh it's just awful
they're so cute
this where she gets taken away from mr.
midnight Fran please follow my voice and
the count of three you will wake up this
when she's in the psychiatric ward one
two three so what I'll do is I'll play
this all again so it looks like it's a
bit different even though it's probably
gonna be you know the same as the demo
I'll put something to click on if you
want to skip it or maybe I'll just make
this one episode
I don't know but and it's quite
different so I still want to play this
because they've obviously you've really
done it again Fran how do you feel ah
that's just like I'm fine just sad to
see the same things sadness or something
everybody has with it what do I want to
do I want to find the killer obviously
you'd want to know who it was
I find my cat and McKenna
your cat is missing it would be
impossible to get but don't think that
nothing's impossible this at midnight
will come back to me but now I have
something for you Fran what is it see
the desk there's a little package for
you
it's from Aunt Grace take it is oh look
look at the cursor it's the middle it's
a capitated hand that's a nice little
touch this was my mother's purse open it
there's something inside
oh no no no examined don't stare astride
here's the purse you like so much I
thought you'd like to have it when I was
thinking about you I remember that you'd
like to examine objects and combine them
with other things so I hope do we always
keep this pass and give it and all the
other things you find a good youth never
forget that creativity is absolutely
greatest gift you have I think that's
very true of other creativity she's
right
Aunt Grace well another reason to let me
go don't worry about her she's fine
can I leave now can I go to my room no I
meant like to leave the place yes you
can leave but before you do it's time to
your new medicine oh no more medicine I
don't want to try more medicine it's
called
duty and it will make you feel very
relaxed nurse we're ready
this medicine this mess I wonder if
they've updated it and made it even more
creepier but they have anything new
today dr. DN nothing actually same
visions as before oh I see here Fran
take your medicine
no offense hey I don't feel good
oh yeah oh no
take her bathroom and nurse don't ever
let her take this again how do I find
the pills that I own braids it's in a
while I haven't played it since I
uploaded it to YouTube last I think it
was last year sometime where Freneau
if you leave the house
I will check it out
catch
and bring you back to insanity
mr. midnight Fred wake up the medicine
will help you escape
I'll be waiting for you in the forest
I'm gonna cap I love you
thank you chapter 1 my sober day oh did
they have chapters and I guess it was
only a demo so it was only chapter one
Oh they've changed it
oh yeah I'm glad I'm playing skin look
at the clown so creepy ok what we're
doing I'm still here hideous place yeah
you are
I have to get out of here yes you do
right I know I'm probably not gonna be
as thorough as I was before patient was
near the Oswald asylum showing signs of
psychosis has tried different
medications canceled because of side
effects red and tiny are hiding from me
where did tiny hates the monster I have
to find mr. midnight I have to find him
now I miss my kitty he hides because he
is afraid told me that the medicine will
show me where he is I miss the killer
too
you don't want to get him badiy I care
my
so creepy
oh I don't think this nice lady was here
before hello Frank
good to see you are awake thank you
now go I'm working oh she's so mean
pills are somewhere hmm
why are you keep the medicine miss how
long was I asleep three days maybe three
days thirty hell was it the medicine yes
it was the medicine that's where you're
not taking it again
but the cutie told me to take it your
cat told you that that it really must be
an evil cat mr. midnight is not evil you
shouldn't say things about anyone you
don't know so I've been realistic now go
I'm working so can I not Kiki you give
me the medicine please D is fine
locked
this boy is creepy kind of fails
how I everybody says that I'm sick that
is stupid
are you leaving tonight I well if you
help me
the only thing I know is that the office
is the key there's a key inside the
office I still the doctor write a secret
code oh yeah I remember that
stick your code to open the yellow door
he doesn't want me to tell you who oh
yeah I remember spit him oh wow he's so
much creepier now all doors are closed
you are prisoners my aim I think and
nobody will help you escape
leave me alone I hate you I would she
said that's a monster oh it's okay
Fran Oh
what other months have stopped me
exactly okay secret box
Shh examine it's open okay it's kind he
had it yeah we 30 creepy doll basin
cubed it all sort of time with his
mother
the boy has developed paranoid behavior
paranoia and not yet diagnosed we have
not achieved the patient's trust and he
refuses to be questioned I wonder why oh
hey mr. wooden horse you having a good
time
okay so the key must be for you yeah so
we got a bobby pin we got a little
photos oh god this of my life
do that I will get your nose
oh oh whoa-hoo-hoo a handy hook I'll
save it to play pirate later something
happens see you are nothing but trouble
what is it oh okay okay I was trying to
look outside negatively broke the
curtains accidentally I have to fix this
follow me I think no I'm going to look
for the pills no she's not
Oh fine
something is missing have you seen the
hook that holds the curtains up
what's a herp play dumb always works but
I have to go and find something to fix
this little girl
they're not very nice are they ha ha yes
band-aids fires trauma can have a great
impact on children for example chosen
damaged by trauma can have mild to
severe deficits and some abilities such
as trusting people near them seeing the
world as a safe place making decisions
etc because that they suspect some
traumas can lead to several symptoms of
major mental illness for example not
trusting other people are not feeling
safe in the world this can be
interpreted as paranoia drawing of the
brain a frontal lobe a motor cortex hmm
trauma is aware the doctor loves to say
he that brain looks like a turtle well
what do you know it doesn't what okay
then as his handwriting is awful it is I
can hardly read it the patient has
something been sleeping almost all the
time she only wakes up to drink water
but I don't think she remembers that
after drinking she goes to sleep again
she hasn't been social for three days
now some kids have come around and asked
about her and when we see were to come
and play okay aha ABCD efg why is H and
8th
it's its circle for some reason you T
crows aah
oh my goodness why would the nurse have
this she wants to kill us all
okay yeah you do need to get out that
place so H and eight its circles and
this has got
this has got
always please so maybe it's nothing h8
but that's except it next four five yeah
yeah I am look at the pills give the
pills okay and now it comes to
creepiness lovely no I have not missed
that but yeah they've definitely meets
oh my gosh annoys us they've definitely
made it a lot more creepy since I bet it
last oh dear poor little rat
okay okay we've got this I hate when
things whisper in my ears
no absolutely not
you cannot tell her that but she has to
know you can't keep me away from her the
reason is more clear grace more than
clear grace no it's not I wanted to get
home now oh it's her aunt
you can't Fran's mental condition is not
appropriate yet oh I just would stick at
home
is that real oh dear Aunt Grace I wonder
what she has to tell me the doctor has
no solo going home tonight
yes you are I'll help you I'll help you
go home
Oh give my head back please
it's just it's just gives me the shivers
it's so creepy that little boy hasn't
changed his head really creeps me out
don't like it
ah so creepy okay let's put the yes put
the lid back on yay back to being normal
much much nicer right okay looks like
summons this way Oh examined right
combine this one with this one I
remember this from the last demo and
then use you can do at the top okay
this is different
it's got stairs now that I don't think
they had a maze oh I want to play in the
maze okay
we ate a pill that wasn't the same thing
as before just notice the light hasn't
been on now it's Brian it blind any
bright but yeah sorry about that
anyway oh my god okay let's just put the
lid back on yeah she's just a normal
girl playing with crayons lovely Oh God
okay what's happening with this game um
hello you see them you do right see what
the creatures that follow everyone
you mean the shudders uh-huh
I can't see them but I know they are
there she knew what they are yeah I
guess
Oh what are they because I'm pretty
creepy tell me please you like to draw I
love to draw on it yeah I love it too
tell me about the shadows crayon a
crayon I want to find a crayon I draw
all the time you have so many crayons
look at them I want to find my cat draw
a cat if you don't have worst that's
true but a drawn cat there's no way as
cool as an actual cat your cat is in
danger the shadows took him I know what
did they know he's in the forest who
told you that the one that follows me by
oh my god that's so creepy she likes
that's mine my crayons I just like this
green crayon so much can I have it no I
won't be able to draw green then that's
ridiculous
but you have so many other colors yes
many colors but you know they don't like
me drawing who the shadows the nurses
they tie me up and when I want to draw I
can't what I say they tie me up
sometimes too it hurts when I can't draw
I hurt myself then the red milk comes
what then comes the bread milk look oh
that's not nice
it kinda reminds you thought of two
fingers use like get my device will to
tell that but this this it's a little
girl please cure me yes and stop the red
milk
I'll see what I can do this is horrible
I just take them all out
they're all so messed up okay see what's
wrong with this girl she's 7 years old
the patient was a victim of sexual abuse
by an unknown person which is almost
which almost killed her
this event has created auditory
hallucinations of thoughts disorder
alright so she can only hear that if she
can't see them eyes closed through
drawing therapy okay but then what why
didn't a NASA stop her drawing them it
does her therapy that makes no sense
it's horrible dating wait
so that is that like the person doing
that it is isn't it
oh that's horrible you can see yep I can
see well that's horrible
so are the shadows they're kind of
demons at their past that they can't let
go of the thing that keeps them in the
in the mental asylum just makes sense I
guess it's clowns everywhere so this
game is just so creepy it doesn't even
need jump scares or anything like that
is just so creepy
well let me see a red puppet and a
serpent oh it's mr. Brad I because I was
really looking forward to this game
coming out so I would watch all that
stuff cause they had some crazy videos
kill Monday games they have crazy videos
about this and he's a puppet called mr.
red and that's him there little red
thing there that's him anyway I'll leave
them the throne is empty I didn't
realize that I wanted to be pooping
crows
the king oh my gosh thank you fish just
little things like that the King likes
drawings okay well he'll love that other
girl then she draws all the time right
let's get it down here Oh nurse go away
she'd be in over him you've left the
door open I'm sure it was not open I
know because I locked it well how did I
get out there don't try to trick me go
inside your room and wait for the doctor
I don't want to go back it's horrible in
there that's their time for this I have
to find my way out
yes yes a doctor
did you break out from your room that's
not nice brand but I'm hungry sir I
haven't eaten in days I won't listen to
any of your excuses young lady sir
doctor please just let me go out and eat
something you have to learn how to
listen to those in church of course
their lesson learn just don't drink in
front go and eat now then back to bed
see just act like the innocent lovely
sweet girl and you get away with
everything so easy
no escape beeping noise
I wonder what blinking light is for the
reception room
you always find a NASA man
get your hands at the of odds of his
door
patience
no one's visited Fran phil was here
today oh right oh never mind
so the key hanging up there can I have
it sure give me the key if you give me a
kiss what kiss your butt why would he
say that to her this place is just weird
that some creepy girl hello are you all
right
what is that supposed to mean I just
wanted to know if you feel okay
I don't want to tell the doctor will cut
your head open if you don't leave it's
Mike it might be true he likes to eat
brains
okay maybe not for that I was thinking
more of like a lobotomy or something
like that he already took mine he ate
all of my thoughts he ate your brain
he will eat yours too I saw you inside
the doctor's office you were dead I
wouldn't that I was passed out oh no
then I have to go I hope you find these
thoughts by I wonder what should we see
what she looks like with pills oh wow
yeah she definitely looks like she's
eating Teddy what are you doing here I
will laugh at you I will lie to you I
will hide you in the shadows that's
creepy whispering my ear again okay
serve it is scary goodness oh I remember
this room demo just a glance grandfather
Club is big and grand let's talk to the
nurse hello
oh hello Fran how are you today does she
how she care about me I see ten animals
I see dead animals miss you mean in the
television of course the television very
well Frank go play with your friends now
okay this isn't the radio signal it's
weird what have we here chocolate mmm
yummy oh yeah she did say she was hungry
I see the cinnamon bun melting in my
mouth that eat it
I used to cinema bum with you oh okay
she doesn't actually want to eat it fair
enough hello are you new here I haven't
seen you before no are you from
downstairs uh-huh they think I'm better
now what's your name
could you please kill me I I'm not okay
I'll say short I shut up Brian you're
dead thank you I can't talk now I'm dead
that's really creepy
it's just Larry it's so creepy let's
have a look what they've it like with
the pills what is he doing they hired
you because they love you what they harm
you because they hate you
Oh little boy everyone feels ashamed of
you oh no the lady nurse died mommy
loved to paint roses okay back on
this is difference there others knows a
boy here before
hey hey Carol what are you doing no but
hey honey how are you
aren't you afraid of me no why would I
because I can do magical tricks and make
you sleepy that's what tricks I don't
know good show me show you but it's very
scary it's better if you do it I can't
I'm not a magician I can give you the
magical stuff
really oh yes the magical stuff that
will make anyone fall asleep maybe the
guy is who's guarding the office door we
can make him go to sleep oh that's
amazing powerful and grand here as a
gift take it slowly thank you
all right how does it work I have no
idea this well thank you very much
let's see you see you later I okay then
let's have some milk I know what this
I'm not hungry
you've told him you're such a good liar
I guess if Damian eats the pasture it
can't be that bad
oh he's just he just likes disgusting
things
don't touch my sword
it's the cane I didn't know it was yours
you should bow and speak to me clearly I
am your king you are not the king I'm
only the king of the whole universe bow
to me don't bow to him Franz forget it
do I have to bow to him to make things
happen don't disturb me go away I'm
eating Oh fine
oh why bout you sir very well my child
what is your purpose of your visit
I want your walking cane what walking
cane do you mean my sword yes your
highness your sword what would you give
me in exchange I cinema done anything
you need your highness bring me a castle
on a horse only then will I grant you my
sword right yeah like that's that's
realistic isn't it jack kids these days
what is it crazy
a deal of strength amount like your
kitten's suddenly she's not my cat
she is what's in this the stores always
all tonight I can't go out to play pills
this room from the demo and I was like
damn I'm dead I'm speaking to them ah
it's alive who are you that holy man
took all your clothes off
oh how pretty all these roses are right
your mummy doesn't believe you horrible
okay let's put this back home oh oh here
she is
I said she was home kids okay so what
have I gotten here so I could maybe use
I've got a sleeping pill I've got
bandages I've got a hook I've got bunch
of my family in this cinnamon oh I've
still got one moonfish a coyote
oh delivery I liver pills okay well this
is the creepy room and it looks like his
head's been cut open let's talk to him
hello
what are you doing it doesn't work the
paper is not working what do you mean
the paper should be working like they
told me but what does the paper has to
do I need the paper to show me what's on
the television that's not that's not how
things work there's none how TV works oh
I see but why isn't it working the waves
must be powerful change the channel
please do you want me to change the
channel okay I'll do that
it's a car cake
human testing approved that's not good
harvest food for the winter I can't be
that fine what mother's creepy one it
works it works a miracle thank you
paper Vision+ great can I see no this is
mine if you want you can take the papers
that didn't work okay I suppose I can
use it I'm busy
paper vision of revision interaction
okay let's take the paper then well now
I can buy Totoro when I'm bored but you
still need a crayon um what was I
supposed to do for that girl to get the
crayon little paper boat take me to the
sea and beyond the action men should
either of you help me find my kitty
this is miniature Manas a cowboy the
soldier lost his lemon war would you
like to help me escape is about I don't
think she's waking up do you
that's one creepy doll good night shiny
toys okay let's do the pills
oh my gosh
that's horrible oh no they did it all
wrong look at me I say I care why you're
dying appengine about hunger and thirst
I say you're beautiful while I give you
poison to eat look at me I say I love
you while I'm teaching you to hate
yourself these shadows wake up Isabelle
the black shadow is touching you it's
Thursday you're going to die so you know
you're afraid of death I hope not
because it may happen even if you don't
like it oh it's so creepy
Oh Isabelle I hope we don't die that was
the girl that gave us the tablets right
sorry
okay let's try our way
yeah that's try giving giving you this
here sir Oh what about if we stuff it Oh
in Cinnabon Oh stupid cake then we can
give it to him
I bought this cake for you I'm not
interested in taking anything that comes
from you
please it will make your life a bit
sweeter I don't care about making my
life sweeter now leave so you don't want
it no now leave me alone not done it was
a good idea
come on it was good but it's why I
didn't the demo so I can't read
hello oh there wasn't the girl who gave
us a thing then she said okay let's go
back up to that down with the crayons
because I know she wants something from
us I can't remember what what did you
wanna get please cure me and stop the
red milk I see what I can do so how do I
show you maybe maybe you oh I've got
bandages ah
why don't I think of that before oh
thank you you can have the crayon now go
I have to draw okay so if I remember
rightly I
oh no examine I can combine this and I
said yeah draw him a horse and I could
parcel such a good idea it's so funny
that he takes it as well and now we can
go downstairs just if you do give him is
horseman and his castle is he's so
important he is the king oh no don't let
me go out to my room hey Gladys will you
do me a favor sure anything but bring
the show her anything might bring the
coffee to the guy why not I can't do
because I have to take care of the
children I have other things to do
myself sorry
what are you doing
okay she's gone now Safari went outside
but I have this oh that's beautiful
exactly what I dreamt of blessing you
can take my sword now it's yours
thank you for the cane I don't even know
what I need it for they might eat this
came for
maybe if I combine it with oh wait okay
so I combine this with this and then I
can use this so I can get the keys off
the hook with this used to the policing
and I'm not too sure what to do and
everything else I've still got the crown
do you really not want my cinema burn
Wow
we actually have to kiss him to get that
key look Tara if you keep coming here
we'll be able to control my your wha
why are you coming on to me do you love
me what is wrong with this guy if you
keep coming here we'll be able to
control myself
ah what is wrong with this guy freak
yeah there didn't she
maybe no I didn't she I didn't cheat but
I know I know it's due now we are going
here
no we're not we are going in here but
we're following this girl round and
begin this coffee because I didn't I
didn't pick it up I'm stupid and let me
go over to this guy and then you know
what we do
oh yes you can guess here's your hot hot
hot coffee sir
oh yeah look at her face she's so badass
look what you did you insane orphan
[ __ ]
I can't well you did that on purpose
they're awful here now I have to go and
change guys it's burning like hell
don't go anyway will she oh my god so
awful no wonder she wants to get out
this place I'm gonna help you go and get
this she's such an idiot of course I'm
going to now do this on I yes yes nice
okay now this room is creepy the yellow
typewriter yay no pictures of funny
riddles ah that sucks
but there's a key here oh it's always
good to carry an extra key um the doctor
ate an apple okay I hate this bed the
doctor used to sit here and do nothing
oh my gosh it's me and a shadow sitting
on my intestines that's terrifying even
though your eyes are open you can't
understand even though your eyes are
bleeding you can't feel don't hide what
hurts let it hurt you
Oh every time I get shivers I'm not even
joking I do get shivers I was just
keyholder huddled keys okay
wonder what people do with all this
gatherings
testing day every day is testing day
turn off the alarm
old of the code and something important
seen this before what does it mean that
like the witchcraft symbol I don't know
you're not alone join us today
oh yeah it's hurting day what a lovely
painting I wish I could draw like that
you can Fran what a tiny text thoughts
of Marcel dearest okay alright let's
leave oh film
I've forgotten girl with no family your
cat will die when the moon arise how
creepy is that what do you mean okay
the pics are all the same Phil oh let
her out is there anything in this great
I don't want to know what this is it's a
great oh yes look at this
turn off the alarm from the security
system put on a live show from the
Yellow Door will remain in for two
minutes and TV alarm reactivates alarm
code December 17
July 25th the code is very important
nothing here oh my gosh it works that
actually works
oh that's creepy oh the wind hall I
guess this is my way back are you gonna
crawl I reckon I wonder if film knew
about this creepy that run really hit
his head I should give it a helmet huh
oh I love the way she thinks I'll just
keep going and going you're gonna fall
go Fran
okay this is different I didn't fit the
seven oh dear where are we now I didn't
mean the rest the map a mop that was
danced on the floor will it really them
oh if I were which I could fly away from
here yeah there we go ha cleaning
products they should clean our toilets
oh they're not clean the toilets sponges
and washcloths and thousands of
chemicals okay anyway enough about mops
and cleaning supplies there's nothing
under the blanket all what's in here and
the box is open let me see oh so many of
those pills I just take them to find my
kitty scrapes label hmm yellow pills
they look more fun than the red ones I
wonder why I get red pills instead of
yellow maybe they just ran out of the
color the gloves tell me nothing all the
nurses wear gloves I could take it and
taste it but I don't want to besides
some good thing to eat things that way
it's not good to eat things that could
be bad the patient's voila I'm guessing
that's her is our current habit
targets on response is positive now
expanding the triggered gland
change the container so it looks like an
approved variant of tua team oh so have
they been making their worst versions of
medicines that's not good not good at
all
okay okay so let's take the pill lies in
a box you really lose your head in this
place yep let's go p.m. ah maybe this is
what the keys to this is turning out to
be a really long playthrough Oh
if you struggle you will know that I
that it was I I will be in every corner
to make you suffer and cry if you choose
to disobey your cat's life will be
marked okay Wow
oh my dear kitty will soon be together
again I promise I miss you my dear I
miss you so much why are you leaving
please don't leave me alone mister
midnight and maze
at the end of the maze fried sweet
waiting for her at the end of the base
hello i framed it again I wonder if my
dreams are true the monster won't let me
go home but if I find the maze maybe I
can find mr. midnight maybe okay I'm
gonna have to end it there because it is
actually been quite a long plating
hasn't it I'm sorry if it's been too
long I'll try and cut it down for you
but I was having a lot of fun playing
this and I really hope you are enjoying
watching it I will continue very soon
please give this a thumbs up if you
enjoyed it and let me know if you
definitely want to see more of this
because I'll be playing more of it
regardless so yeah have love you dare
evening bye hey guys today I have a big
favor to ask you
it's all a big really actually what I
want you to do is just get comfy and
watch the whole of this video cuz I'm
going to play the whole of the fourth
episode of life is strange